ام عيد مارنقول في اوكرانيا همم كيف
عاشتها باخمو تحديدا التي توجهت اليها
اليوم ميساء
وهذا النهار هو نهار مميز بالنسبه الى
الاوكرانيين الذين يتبعون تقويم الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه هنا وتجري العاده فيه لتوزيع
الهدايا على الاطفال بطبيعه الحال الاجواء
صعبه للغايه في مدينه محمود القصف كان
مستمرا تحديدا المدفعيه التي كانت تنطلق
من الجانب الاوكراني وتقابل بمثلها من
الجانب الروسي زرنا احد النقاط التي تجمع
فيها عدد كبير نسبيا من النساء من النساء
والاطفال
العمر
راينا هناك هذه العائله همم مع اطفال
ثلاثه في المدينه قال لنا للاطفال كم من
المهم ان يكون في تماثل مع اخرين بعد ما
دقه في قلب لمده ايام عديده اللي فيها هذا
المركز تحدي همم لانه هناك مولدات
كهربائيه خفت لغايه الشحن الهواتف نرى همم
حضور كثيرين لهذه الغير للحصول على تدفئه
لطعام
قدر الامكان وقدر ما تسمح به الظروف ويبدو
انه
رغم القصف والرغم المعارك التي تشتد في
الضفه الشرقيه من هذه المدينه بحسب ما
قالته لنا متطوعه يبدو ان القديس نيكولاس
لم ينسى المرور على بخموت لنستمع
سمعت منك والله
اليوم هو اتى الينا البارحه مساءا عندما
كان الاطفال نائمين
كلفني بتوصيل الهدايا قال لي يا دنيا
عنها
لا ان تعود الامور الى طبيعتها هنا لدينا
كلنا نحتاجه لدينا بيت اصدقاء ومعارف
والعديد منهم لا يزال هنا لن نريد ان
نغادر مدينهنا مازلنا نستطيع تحمل الوطن
بحسب اخر الارقام فان اكثر من 95% من سكان
هذه المدينه غدروها هذه المدينه التي كانت
تعد سبعين
الاجواء مين التعاضد هناك محاوله قدر
الامكان من قرروا البقاء بان يسير وييسر
امورهم بما توفر لكن هذه المهمه غير سهله
اليوم خلال جولتنا داخل المدينه الجزء
تماما الا من الجنود الاوكرانيين وحاله
الصدمه والتوتر كانت واضحه للغايه تحديدا
عند كبار العمر الذين رايناهم والذين
بيموا عظمهم باتوا واحد اثنين وليس لهم من
يعيلهم ويعتمدون بشكل كامل على المساعدات
الانسانيه
تواجده في المدينه نقطه اخيره نعلم ان
هناك العديد تحديدا من المساعدات الغذائيه
المقدمه من قبل مثلا برنامج الامم المتحده
همم داخل المدينه لكن المتطوعون يخاطرون
احيانا بحياتهم من اجل ايصارها لاشخاص
يصعب عليهم الخروج من منازلهم ومن اغنيتهم